everybody welcome so we have nina
unrated
hi guys wow cool so uh yeah
this is uh actually is your real name is
your real first name uh nina you wanted
to go by nina
no well yeah yes we're going by nina
i didn't i didn't know if that was
actually legitimate sure you know what's
funny is when i hit you up to do this
you know what the first thing i noticed
i hit you up and i was like hey i got to
sing i do
and the first thing that you said to me
when when we spoke was um
he said you said first off uh how are
you
how's your day well just give me one
second over here
let me just uh fix this yeah the first
thing you said was
um how are you how's your day and i
started chuckling because i was like
she didn't even get to the offer yet you
just went straight to
manners and how are you and i thought
that was a cool start i was like okay
cool
yes i'm doing good how's your day and
you're like oh my day's good
now let me read this real quick right
let me get to it now
do you feel like people online just go
straight to stuff like they forget
manners
um i think a lot of the times people
just
don't want to waste their time they want
to get to the point so
when i see somebody that wants to get to
the point my initial instinct is to
really want to know how they're doing
because i already know i'm going forward
you see what i'm saying so i'm like well
let's back it up a little bit that way
we can get to know each other and go
from there so the vibe is more important
than anything else if you catch an
energy from somebody and it seems like
they're just
they're going to be just as cool as you
then you can go forward
so yeah that makes sense do you so um
for people who don't know
what what do you do for work
i am a strip fluencer youtuber
actress i've been in the sex work
industry since i was 18 years old i am
on
level 42 of my life journey so i have
three youtube channels uh the big
channels where i show girls how to twerk
i say story times i teach them how to
get their money easy shortcuts
lean on rated vlogs is the actual behind
the scenes of the strip club life
um recognized for the new york times and
then nina already eats is
me eating chopping it up with my
homegirls i have a fanbase of 96.4
females so i just talk about real [ __ ]
wait am i not the curse bro no yeah you
can say whatever you want we're good
we're good
no no we're
[Music]
and you said you said a term i never
heard before you said str
strip food strip reflect oh no you don't
have to say that
strip strip fluency instead of
influencer okay okay so that's like
strippers who do like the influencer
thing
exactly yeah all right i'm not gonna
friend you that just sounds like it
sounds like a disease i don't know if
y'all want to keep that
you don't think about that first i i saw
the strip throat
oh because you got first you got
influenza then you got stripped
and i'm left with the damn stds like you
said you said strip fluence
first time i heard it made me jump i i'm
not familiar with a lot of these terms
um yes no it's your influencer it's um
just you know influencing the stripper
lifestyle that's a proper term in my
i think i think it suits it very well
because that's what we're doing we're
influencing
the entire lifestyle so instead of
downgrading it
you know put it up a notch yeah and i
want to ask you of the three channels
that you run which one's the one that
you enjoy doing the most
honestly i love my nina raider vlogs
um because there's so much negative
things out online in regards to
strippers sex workers hookers
prostitutes
and i'm like let me show the lighter
side of this life there's a lot of
educated women that work in our field
and it's always so negative like they're
they're drug addicts they're you know
alcoholics they're bad mothers they're
uneducated it's i mean it's just so
they're savage with it when they talk
about us
sex workers a lot of the terms are very
savage so
i think with anybody who works in that
realm if you work in anything related to
sex
or um money for you know your physical
looks or whatever
i find people are extra harsh on people
who do that kind of work
is crazy sorry to cut you off um no no
my thing is this because i'm gonna just
treat you like i'm talking to you like
on facetime i don't even
lie right now so
the same people that are criticizing us
those are our number one participants
i noticed that i actually noticed that
the people who are most vehemently
against it oftentimes are the ones who
are
either most susceptible to it or two
most involved in it and they're very um
some people are very uh loud with their
insecurities so
we being so open with our life first of
all i was never open about
being a health um or a stripper or a
prostitute or
an escort there's a lot of different
terminologies in the sex work industry
i was exposed online and i i've never
been the kind of person that
i think you know hoenn is real private
like your clientele
is real private so you you don't want
that
out in the open so my entire life was
exposed
so for me it's like the people that
criticize the most is
they have to criticize it in public
because in private
it's a different book it's a different
ballgame yeah i've heard of that too
because um a friend of mine she does
uh she does a bit escorting actually is
actually the girl came on the first
episode she told yeah i saw her i'm like
oh my me and baby girl come by real
quick
i need to be meeting her with you yeah
you know
azure is cool real deal yeah yeah she's
awesome
good smile oh yeah she's getting her but
all she's gonna do is smile
yo flawless stop playing i'm like yeah
see about that bread
is it is it because you've got so much
time in the game that you know when
people got potential when people got it
oh yeah it's i've been i mean 24 years
of
i didn't deal with just one entertainer
i've seen
thousands okay thousands and thousands i
mean i've rotated clubs
states that's 24 years of i was out for
about
five years cold turkey because i got
into a relationship a real serious
relationship so i got out all the way
but
um yeah you can kind of tell who who
knows how to get their money and who's
just
doesn't understand the program it's a
home it's a game out here like for real
thrill so when you know how to play the
game
and you understand that you really got
to just play chess are you good
so she you know baby girl she you know
she's only a year in
but she's season she she's seen some
[ __ ] but she a baby in the game
that's fine we say the same thing when
people you know even the comedy game
like when people are fresh in
you know open micros or whatnot you know
the difference between that and when you
many many years in the game doesn't
matter what age you are
when you get in but it's about the time
in yeah but you know one thing
he's deadly bro
what why is that was it
[Laughter]
yeah and that's something you can't
teach i find i find there's a certain
level of charm
and personality that you can't teach
people i mean you could work out and get
you can shape
there's a lot of things you can but i
think with something like um this is
specifically
and i say this even with dating sex
appeal i find
something very different than whether or
not you look sexy i feel like there's a
difference between those two things
there's a way you can carry yourself and
talk to people that gives you sex appeal
versus
being very physically attractive or very
being like alluring
correct i've seen the ugly i've seen
ugly girls that would i'm not calling
anybody
ugly no no no we could do that we can do
that
no i've seen people that wouldn't be
considered attractive
have more swag yeah than the baddest
[ __ ] in the club
yeah because when you're not that cute
like that
you gotta develop a personality so now
you gotta know how to talk to people
sometimes the bad bridge has no
conversation for you and that's how they
lose in the game they don't educate
themselves on people
versus what will be and i don't mean
this to be offensive but we have a term
called the ugly duckling in the in
in the strip club sometimes makes just
as much money
as the girls that be up there in the
game because she knows how to talk
yeah and what you're talking about is
also true even in real life like yo
you know i've met a few it doesn't
happen too often but i've met a few
women with some game and i was like oh
it's a different balkan hold on now you
talk about game just to spit a little
bit at you you i heard you say that you
thought you was ugly
was you i mean i i mean no i wasn't i
wasn't so so the thing is
here's the thing here's the thing i'm
not today and i'm not
now but when you grow up most of your
life thinking that way it's hard to get
yourself out of it right
it's like it's like if you pour most of
your life
even when you get money you still have a
poor man's mindset in a lot of ways
you might have cash but you may not know
how to hold on to it or how to manage it
or to feel comfortable
like even now that i got cash like i
don't feel comfortable in bougie-ass
spots it just makes me uneasy i feel
like i don't belong
you know what i'm saying so it's a it's
a mindset so that
you know when you young and you spend
most of your life a certain type of way
and and you get these rejections or
whatever then you get used to something
that's what you're used to you think of
yourself that way so let me ask you this
uh-huh do you think your confidence now
because now you know
i just want you to i just want to know
if you're if you think this do you think
you're physically attractive
i think i'm physically attractive too
yeah i would say like to some people i'm
definitely
today okay you know i'm saying i'm kind
of flagged
on me right i'm doing all right for
myself i'm doing much better than i was
before yeah i think the confidence
came because you got finances in order
or do you think it came because you got
your maturity in order
no it had nothing to do with money
there's like a misconception that people
have but like since i started working
all the time and
doing all this [ __ ] full time like i i
date and i'm out there way less
than when i was before uh for me my
confidence came from one experience
into reflection that's where my
confidence came from the more i was out
there the more i was dating the more i
was talking to women
and the more experience i got and the
more comfortable i got in those
scenarios
the more comfortable and confident i
have so it doesn't matter if the girls
are 10
or 12 or a 3 i'm going to talk to them
the same way because for me i'm not
phased by it anymore you feel me right
okay
all right like even for you i'm sure i'm
sure it's the same for you right like
once you've seen those high value
clients or those ballers
and those regular dudes like you know
how to talk to everybody you're good to
go
i i learned how to talk to uh
a lot of different kind of people
because i was exposed to so many people
like on cue like
every night was 100 new people so i had
to develop
put it this way when i first started
stripping i wasn't the baddest [ __ ] in
the club
i went there my first night i didn't
even know how to shave my [ __ ] like i
didn't know
these things i didn't know that i had to
wear sections of litter so i showed up
with sandals and [ __ ]
my bad
that night when you showed up in sandoz
did you make some money
yo i did yo hey let's go
yo but the game was different back then
the game was different back then
okay okay back then dudes was just happy
with just really looking at you and be
like oh my god i can't believe you had
the nerve
to take the panties off in front of me
like i i did it in boston where we was
like raw opening up our [ __ ] like
you know they was giving us ob gyn exams
in the strip club where i started
i said at an all new club right right
some people aren't broken into that so
to me it was like um it was it was a lot
of that so i had to mature a lot so the
game was different than what it is now
but
i wasn't one of those girls that was put
together i had to learn how to put
myself together but when i came back the
second shift oh you best believe
you're alright wait a minute yeah you
learned i just like looked at one of
these [ __ ] broke him down i'm like
her hair her toes her nails her lashes
her makeup
hold on a second she got titties ass her
shoes i broke it down from head to toe
and then i would just duplicate it and
when i walked in the next night i was
like who's this [ __ ]
they had to re-audition me right right i
want to ask you
now do you feel like you're comfortable
in your own habits that you've like kind
of crafted for yourself
in regards to what to how you dress into
how you hold yourself to the things that
you do
would you say you're like fit by
industry standards or is nina and rey
doing things her own way
i've always done things my own way
that's probably why my brand hasn't
developed as
fast as many other youtubers
um i've never been in the box i've never
i've worked regular jobs and done
regular things and had a square
lifestyle for a while but
i've never fit into an actual specific
genre
on youtube so i'm still developing my
brand because it's kind of taboo in a
way
yeah i'ma say this what you spoke about
is literally how most people learn any
craft
when you um when you jump into comedy
for example or you dance
you know you start off by imitating the
people you see around you that are doing
well
and as you imitate them and you start to
replicate you break down okay
this is where he moved here and whatever
then after some time you start to
develop into your own as you get more
comfortable in the game
but initially yeah you don't know what
you're doing so you just copy whoever
and that's how you have to start so it's
just interesting to hear you talk about
stripping that way because i never
thought of it that way but i'm realizing
it's all the same [ __ ]
yeah it is and there's so many different
levels to it it's kind of like like you
said like if you start a new job if you
start anything that's new and you're a
baby or something there's
you gotta see i never had i didn't have
somebody be like hey yo come here [ __ ]
let me take a look at my winger let me
show you what the game is
i made a bunch of mistakes when i
started stripping like
you're not supposed to be dating
customers but that's where i met my baby
daddy turned out he was an [ __ ] so
you know [ __ ] like that like you
you there's certain things you shouldn't
be doing like you shouldn't be dating
people from the club
you should just be tricking off of them
don't try to build something with
somebody making a club because no matter
what
and it's that to say they're not ever
going to give you the level of respect
you know you deserve when you get out
the game
it don't work like that hold up uh
i i'm gonna say one thing and then i
want to actually ask you a question
about that uh
actually when you go to comedy clubs
they say the same thing when you're
working don't date any of the wait staff
don't they anybody who works at that
economy club
oh yeah you can't do that because if you
come back around the next time and it
went south they don't bring you back
there's a lot of
there's actually rules in a lot of like
uh comedy clubs where they say
if you [ __ ] the wait staff i'll never
bring you back as a headliner well
i would say that regular clubs are
where the new holes are at now the open
hose is in the strip club
the low keyholes are bottle service
girls
waitresses are these high-end clubs but
have the right opportunity to come along
because these waitresses get
i'm just gonna spit on that real quick
these waitresses get just as much
attention as we do when we're naked as a
matter of fact they get more attention
right because the mystery is still there
they haven't seen that bitch's nipples
right they haven't spanked their ass yet
because you're not supposed to do that
right so they're they're just the new
the real good hulk you know they got a
little bit of education they got the
little bartender license that you know
they're working on these high scale
they know how to talk to people they
don't know how to move but they still
selling that's the same way as we do at
the clubs
yeah i actually i actually was i wanted
to ask you about this
um but you said before that they don't
show you the same level of respect
if you is it is it if you leave the club
for somebody you're dating is that what
you said
for example like
the shrimp clubs raised me right so i
was there so much at a time it's like
where the hell am i going to meet
somebody
and you start questioning a lot of [ __ ]
so then i was like okay if i meet
somebody in this club
this dude gonna have to have some money
he's gonna get me out the game like [ __ ]
this
thinking that me and this person would
have been able to bond in a different
level he
you know he saw the world me like he saw
how i got money so we're gonna get out
now
and he's gonna respect him in a
different level that never happens hmm
because why remember he could always go
back to that but i met you at the club
right he was in the nfl in my situation
i got out with an nfl athlete for five
years and then he went broke let's not
even talk about that
so but there was some shady [ __ ] that
would happen i'm like oh wow
this dude will never see my value
because of where he met me like he
wasn't
at the mature level that i needed him to
be to understand like yo
i'm just a hustler right like this is
just my hustle if i tell you that i'm
gonna get the [ __ ] out
it's me you'll be rocking different i'm
sure that i'm thoroughbred like
for real he never saw that because he
met me at the club
and in return i should have never took
him seriously because i met him at the
club
you don't just go one way no yeah yeah i
mean i think for most folks how you meet
does matter to some degree and
especially in this environment like that
that kind of changes a lot
and also considering what you do i know
for some people even though they can
intellectually want to say
i'm over it or i'm not thinking about it
for a lot of people it still stays in
the back of their mind but i'd have to
ask
what is what is dating like for you
considering what you do
how how different is that right i'm
i'm different i'm different i don't know
i'm transparent as [ __ ] i'll tell you
right now you need to google me
oh man hey yo yo i really want to keep
it with you like yo you fly as [ __ ] yo
bro google me
just when you if you can get past
everything you see on
right and you understand that this is a
work and you understand
what the [ __ ] i gotta do then maybe
maybe maybe i might rock with you but
right now i'm just doing a lot of
[ __ ] like
okay yeah dating
i'm not looking for a relationship bro
like i'm good
i've been single since like in my mind
since since like
may of like last year because you know
you really ain't broken up until you
leave a [ __ ] you're feeling
yourself
right nah i'm good i'm just you know
catching all the dick i can
be your mother
hey i even mad at you you know what i
mean listen as long as you could sleep
well at night and you good with it
whatever
other people want to say [ __ ] them i'm
gonna be real right go ahead hit me
down right now yes let's go
if if you say hey yo nina i [ __ ] with
you like
i've gotten to know you for a little bit
i i've kicked it wrong with you like
you're not raw like sex [ __ ] i'm
talking about raw like i'm
real [ __ ] and you understand who i am
and you i'm like that you're me and you
was about to commit and go on a
different
on a different level everything that was
behind me
you ain't even got to worry about like
i'm gonna give you my word because
literally that's all i have
right you see what i'm saying like my
being my being i'm not talking about
materialistic things
what comes out of my mouth is what the
[ __ ] i mean and i want to mean what the
[ __ ] i say so we're going to build
together
[ __ ] it's just me and you now
don't go around doing a [ __ ] like me
dirty
because i'm gonna make sure that if you
catch one [ __ ] i'ma catch 10 dicks and
they're probably going to be your
homeboys
so don't try to play me because it's not
gonna go good you said you when i was
gonna build together i told you i was
gonna put the dick on hold and it's
gonna be your dick and this [ __ ] having
conversations on a regular level we're
gonna do some nasty [ __ ] what you went
to
tell me what you're into so you don't
have to go nowhere else but if you try
to blame me
oh no i'm gonna call the whole back now
[ __ ] you need to come back up in here
cause this [ __ ] try to play your
[ __ ] on me
no no no for all his boys line them up
because
i gave it to you however you wanted it
and you still play me
no baby we're not doing that
i'm talking about all your boys with me
and then i'm gonna cut you off and i'm
gonna move up to the next [ __ ]
that's if i give you my commitment i
don't i don't play with no whole [ __ ]
because a commitment
that word has meaning yes you feel what
i'm saying
yes do you do do you find it i don't
know what you're saying no no i i i get
i get what you say 100 do you feel like
folks
um from your perspective nowadays are
less or has this always been the case
like in terms of commitment like
people on some [ __ ] [ __ ] i just feel
people aren't honest with themselves
right right you could be single you
don't have to get into a relationship
with a male or a female
you could just be single and then say
hey
i'm just gonna see you for right now but
if it don't work out i'm gonna let you
know that i might be seeing somebody
else
just be honest with yourself because the
thing is
most people want to find security and
know that somebody got they
back 100 because that they really knew
that they didn't have their back the
same because they was out here doing
what they were doing it'd be different
right you understand what i'm saying
that's why your commitment comes in
don't get yourself into a committed
relationship don't call the [ __ ] your
girlfriend
don't call her wifey don't don't don't
call her your [ __ ]
i'm engaged to this [ __ ] don't do that
just be like hey yo my this is me and
you be kicking under some real real [ __ ]
you're not the only one but when i'm
with you i'm gonna make sure you're not
disrespected
ain't nobody's gonna walk up on you
acting funny but just know that i'm a
single man
and this dick is not going on just one
[ __ ] that's what women got beef with
y'all be lying
yeah but but you know you know the thing
is most dudes i find lie because they
think you guys
won't like the truth or i won't accept
it even even though you
kids don't want no you're right most
[ __ ] don't want the truth all right
exactly
who the [ __ ] you are so that you can
find the [ __ ] that's about that life
yeah but that means we're passing up on
a lot of [ __ ] that's what's going on so
dudes is trying to smash it if you
letting them know that
you're not listen you're not listening
i'm giving you the game i'm a woman if
you tell it on the up and up
first of all you look more appealing to
a [ __ ]
damn it's not just me you put a
competitive heat underneath
because there's five other hoes are
[ __ ] weird you better be lucky if i
choose you in other words
a man need to let these [ __ ] know
like yo there's ten [ __ ]
and i'm looking for the one i'ma marry
but i'm not committed to any one of
y'all
watch these [ __ ] come over here oh
one gotta clean better than the other
one gotta suck your dick better than the
other one gotta be sexier than the other
they're gonna competing for your
affection that you could make the choice
of who the [ __ ] you could [ __ ] with the
most
or by yourself but don't commit that's
fraudulent [ __ ]
i i agree but i'm trying to say from the
male perspective what they think is
gonna happen when they're telling you
the truth
they think you're gonna be like deuces
or they think you're gonna be
it's causing drama like asking them a
bunch of questions that they don't want
to answer
so if you do it from the beginning
women do that [ __ ] when you say [ __ ]
like this in your mind
huh it's just me and you shorty ain't
nobody else
yeah you know i love you mom we don't
have them babies i'm gonna buy you that
crib
you feel this dick all up in your spine
mommy yeah yeah that's my dick
call my name you saying all that scoop
you're telling me what it is or what's
going to happen i'm telling you what we
think is going to happen
right right right so those are two
different things what you're saying is
most likely gonna happen i would agree
with you for the most part
what i'm trying to say is what den are
thinking if they were to i agree
you know i mean they think it's gonna go
left they think it's like oh okay she
gon
she gonna not gonna want to smash or she
gonna give me headaches so it's just
easier
if i tell her some lies no and it's true
and it is easier
but it's easier at the beginning
you got the [ __ ] the amount of [ __ ]
that is powering up like a snowball at
the end of that game homie
it wasn't worth it as she showed up at
your job knocking on your door slashing
your tire
key in your car calling your baby mama
yeah
it wasn't worth it yeah trust me women
want to know
i'm telling you from a female
perspective i've seen it i've witnessed
it
women want to know that they got the
dude to choose gum
keep an open playing field but yeah
you're right you're absolutely right
that is exactly what they think
i better not be honest because if i'm
honest she gonna dig most of them will
most of them will but they'll be back
now i want to ask i want to ask do you
do you think
do you think that your perception of
like the female experience is different
because the environments that you roll
and the people that you're normally
around and i'm making a lot of
assumptions want to say
okay so can you speak to that how do you
feel like that shit's different
because also be honest you know
sometimes like people send me links to
girls who are talking right and they're
talking about how like
they want this or that out of a man and
i'm like where did she live and the girl
be like
uh the person who's in the video was
talking she'll be like she'll be from
miami and i'm like well they got
different sets of expectations than a
girl who lives in [ __ ] wyoming
you feel me like yeah it's not the same
everywhere you know like even the idea
of like plastic surgery it's more
accepted in certain areas
than it is in other parts of the country
i'm not saying it doesn't happen ever
very true
but you know if i go to miami it's a
different ballgame than if i go to
[ __ ]
north dakota all right it's not the same
i'm not going to cc so i want to ask you
how does that affect your perception or
like how's that affected you where
you've kind of
been inoculated or been around i
feel like i feel like i've been blessed
because i've been lucky enough my
perspective is different because i've
been
lucky enough to travel all over
and meet all kinds of different people
so i've always been
i continuously open my mind to new types
of energies and new type of
people and dialogue and food so i'm very
open-minded
most people that i've met
their energy is very much so
one of a hamster where they run
in this nine to five wheel for 20 years
hoping that they get this pension that's
not even guaranteed type [ __ ] because
then they [ __ ] you over because the new
laws change and all kind of crazy [ __ ]
so
they're very boxed in and i've always
feared living in a box so i've always
pushed myself out my thinking is very
open and not judgmental i'm not gonna
pass judgment on uh
i'm just not gonna pass judgment that's
one of the benefits to being exposed to
so many different lives like
or so many different situations if i'm
making any sense at all so i actually
feel blessed that i've been
open to so many things um but most
people
they live in fear i don't i've actually
could look back and be like hey damn
i've lived my life i've done some
some wild [ __ ] like i've jumped out of a
plane and i've traveled the world and
i've gone to london and
went to jail [ __ ] and i got arrested
and i worked at a club and i went to sex
work and i [ __ ] up a senator and i
[ __ ] an athlete
like so much different crazy [ __ ] where
most people have never experienced half
the things i've experienced
so so just on that point i want to ask
you what do you
so you've talked about the upside what
do you think is the cost of that
losing everything yeah so
talk about that losing everything i've
lost everything
so that i can get it all and by
everything i mean i have no family i
don't know where my son is
i haven't heard from my son in years
although i reach out every day
i cut up all my family members all of my
past friends like it's just me like
focusing on where i want to go and what
i want to do with my life so
for you to get this kind of mindset
you have to lose everything break into a
million pieces and then build yourself
back the [ __ ] up you have to do that and
you can only build something back up
once it's been broken as fast
as that sounds but you got the choice on
how you're going to lay those pieces
down
you understand what i'm saying so you're
either going to be like damn everybody
sees me with this dirty [ __ ]
or you're going to be like [ __ ] this i'm
going to capitalize on how everybody
sees me and i'm going to let them see it
in full color i'm taking them to the
club with me i'm taking them here i'm
taking them there
i'm gonna show you i'm gonna show them
where i got this positive mindset from
because everybody talks about how
positive
i can be but they don't understand that
it's a struggle and pain to get there
yeah so it's just a different point of
view in life all together i'm more
spiritual now that i've ever been but i
would have never been able to attain
this level
had i not laid in bed with so many
different men and experienced so many
different type of energies because
that's what you're doing
when you're swapping with it with
another person like that especially for
monetary reasons
you know yeah yeah
i'm their vacation so that's
that's interesting i know it's a lie i
just gave you your life no no no don't
stress it
it's it's good because sometimes i just
need to pause and i just need to think
about it
um there's something that you said that
was interesting you said you had to go
through a lot
in order to get to the point that is and
you said you had to lose
and destroy a lot and i think a lot of
folks missed that point
it's like you know whether it's their
favorite artist or someone that they
admire you know the trajectory towards
getting to that place sometimes is like
very arduous and you lose a lot of folks
and
you lose a lot and it's just interesting
because um
as you speak about like the escorting or
stripping experiences for me it's kind
of like
cathartic because i'm like it's very
similar to stories i hear from people
who
you know i know who are soldiers or who
i know who were um
right uh you know comedians or really
good artists in general it's like
there's a lot of tragedy and um
loss involved in that experience and
before they get to that place of like
some sense of peace some of them never
find it some of them will get consumed
by the loss and then you know
it kills them but um it was just
interesting listening to you talk about
that i'm like
i don't know you you normally you think
of stripping and escorting at such a
random
world with like you know people just
trying to make money and whatever the
[ __ ] but just hearing you speak about it
for me is a little bit different that's
why
i'm thinking about it it's
it's that's all people know it's them
they they go there they go in this
building they get dressed they throw
their clothes on and that's it
we play therapists to a lot of people
we play therapists to other dancers we
play to each other
we play therapists with these men that
we're exchanging our body and our energy
with
for for for their money versus they
don't get a headache and they get
to to vent to us because we're not going
to judge them versus where their wife
are
they can't even open up to their wives
so there's a lot more than just
money on the floor and making the rain
and a bit shaking their eyes
we're actually connected and we meet up
it's crazy because
it's going to sound a little crazy i've
met a lot of good people
like i'm talking about i guess the only
thing you could say at bottom is they
paid a hole
you see what i'm saying but if that's
the worst they ever did
then it is what it is or if they met
some kind of freaky thing about them or
they're like hey you know i want you to
do this for me and i'm gonna hook you up
because i can't go to my wife or my
girlfriend or
i can't do this because i have a certain
type of job
we these people come to us and we're a
black hole to them
meaning they can just pour it all into
us
and it's never ending versus when you
give all that energy to your wife
or your girlfriend or your partner or
your husband
you suck the energy out of them yeah
they don't have it there's so much more
to the street clothes like
i mean i could i could talk to you it's
a lot there's a lot you know i actually
i brought this up with two other people
who had a livestream one was kevin
samuels and the other one was as
we're the girl you watched and both of
them said the same thing it's like you
know people clown on the sex trade but
it's necessities towards some people's
mental health
and well-being is absolutely necessary
it's like people
clowning like oh my god this shit's so
disgusting there's a lot of people out
there
ceos senators successful school teachers
who who don't if they didn't have that
they would not be okay yo right it's not
that they want us
as a matter of fact they don't want us
that's why they got the wife
they don't want us they need us
yeah we're a necessity because we're the
only ones that gonna pull on them
[ __ ] strap-ons they can't go to the
white sushi at home with our three
little kids that wants to soccer
practice and [ __ ] like hey baby you put
the strap on
i'm trying to get it tonight you can't
do that with your wife because it's not
acceptable in society
which is what we come in and be like yo
what you need us to do oh okay what i
said you know it's gonna be another two
thousand dollars daddy well i'm just
saying
you know the price went up a little bit
yeah yeah you know taxes is high and
[ __ ] you know kovac
price but they need that
and i actually asked this to ask you
before but i'm like if society
here's the irony here if society didn't
shame and if society was way more
accepting of the kind of work that you
did and the kind of stuff that goes on
behind closed door
ironically these men would not need to
go to you guys as much because they
would have a much more open space to be
able to do this
we want to stay taboo honey okay okay
all right i was i was thinking about
that because
can people talk about like advocacy and
like removing the type of like
if you take off the taboo then your job
is dead
nah we want to boo boo you stay nice and
square that's what we're here for
we'll never go out of business you know
why because every man just wants more
[ __ ]
one ain't enough sorry you can nothing
is this
this might not be for everybody but if
these women were smart and i'mma spit
some [ __ ] that you might not agree on
but i'm gonna keep it real with you
because i've been on the other side i'm
telling you what your man ain't telling
you [ __ ] pay attention huh
it's like this if
if these wives at home understood their
position
baby girl you ate one especially with a
man with money you ate one you
know one in other words you have access
to all the houses all the credit cards
all the bank accounts you got keys to
all the cards you can do whatever the
[ __ ] you wanna hang on say not to
gotta ask for some permission like hey
daddy come and see me yeah that's gonna
be five thousand like whatever the [ __ ]
you know there's there's rules and
regulations to both parties right so if
if the wife were to open up fully and be
as open as we were we totally be out of
business
100 you said something that was
interesting you said
dudes are always going to need more
[ __ ] yeah
and you know this from like married
dudes and stuff like that like that's
just the way it rolls
i know this from pastors amen to jesus
hallelujah yeah uh-huh
so let me ask you then if you expect
this and you know this to be true
why is it in your personal life you
expect monogamy or or
or that monogamy i never said i expected
that i want you to tell me why i said i
expected monogamy i don't understand
sorry
sorry sorry but commitment right i give
you my commitment in exchange to your
commitment until you play me
right as a timeline it's gonna happen
okay so
so that's my question so that's my
question if you know the inevitable is
coming right which is that they're gonna
want some more [ __ ]
right right why would you want that
knowing the inevitable's coming that's
my question no i
pray but i play different for example if
i get into a committed relationship
it's me and you baby i'm gonna talk to
you it's me and you we in this together
we're gonna do our [ __ ] right all right
let's go let's go i got you and you're
like i'm gonna give you my commitment
your job as a manager like your mom my
dick's a little issue and said i need
another [ __ ] to come scratch this [ __ ]
my job to be like damn inevitably this
man's gonna cheat let me go find the
[ __ ] i want to [ __ ] too
cause now no no no
if you can [ __ ] up i could [ __ ] a two
and if you could [ __ ] another [ __ ] i
could [ __ ] another dude
so i'm just saying that i'm the kind of
[ __ ] that levels up the playing field
so if you can take random [ __ ] then i
should be able to take around and dig
now do you want to watch cause i'm gonna
watch what you thought this [ __ ] i'm
gonna hold her here for you
hold on a second honey you gotta go
deeper no no he don't like it like that
a little bit more
a little bit right there okay daddy like
that
i'll be back i'm gonna go cook for y'all
all right okay so you're a team you're a
team player you're a team player like
that
i'm just saying it does i've seen so
much that i know what the rules are
yeah it's my chess board you see what
i'm saying i've seen it you can't come
and tell me oh yo yo i'm gonna be real
good
i've never in my life i promise you it's
sad to say i've never met a faithful man
every man i've ever tested has failed
every woman that has told me yo can you
test my do for me i'll be like hey yo
failed within minutes because the
opportunity presents itself they can get
away with it they're gonna do it
so why not be open to the idea of hey yo
commitment is not even
loyalty is not real right so let me let
me ask you then
some more questions on that topic is
that a result
of one um what you're looking for to do
to the kind of men that you're meeting
through these environments or
three do you just believe it's the
reality for most
most men i think it's the reality for
most men i think from what i've
experienced and what i've actually
witnessed
it is monogamy is unrealistic
you've never even seen it in history
anywhere there there hasn't been some
award given out for the most faithful
man
on the planet it's always some scandal
on how the straightest edge
dude done [ __ ] up on one [ __ ] like
i'm on the other
side i'm not talking from a perspective
of women that have never even been
exposed
to who they're these women are with men
and they don't even know who their man
is i know who you are you feel me like
yo dude doing [ __ ] with me that you're
never gonna do with you
your dude is not coming to you but like
hey yo i i'm [ __ ] with her because
she waxes her [ __ ]
when you when i bend you over you got
hair coming out yo ask me put on the
thumb it's not even sexy you don't dress
up for me
you don't smell good you don't even
shower properly there's a lot of [ __ ]
that does complain about
and i'm trying to tell these [ __ ]
like yo let me give you the game let me
give you the game
and they're like oh no come on man i'm
like oh i gotta just
your man i just your man
telling you all right not you're not
mikey right you right
now you're right let's make sure you and
i don't sit because it might be paying
my rent
not my key though not mikey yeah
it'd be like that it does and you know
what's funny is that
i think a lot of people don't recognize
how prelim this behavior is
whether you go to like a lot of arab
countries where they got multiple wives
in some situations
and you know it makes sense
they know they know what time it is and
and even like um
you know even in a lot of african spots
like it's just well known that you just
don't complain or you don't say much
about it this is kind of understood
i'm gonna complain if you're broke okay
if you want to have three or four
[ __ ]
you better make sure i'm not missing
nothing papa nothing
you can have whatever what you gonna do
for us she gonna cook
that will go raise the kids this is
gonna teach you math when you need to
raise the [ __ ] around you you
gotta build that unit so
if you if you got a good man and he said
you don't say
and he can take care of all these women
yeah
i don't see no problem with that because
keeping it real don't know [ __ ] wanna
[ __ ] her dude seven days a week
let maria do that on tuesdays right on
thursdays [ __ ] i'm sucking on friday
honey like yeah
[Music]
just don't bring home no secret kids no
stds
and make sure they're home sticking out
but
that's where the problem comes in why
are you going out [ __ ] other bedroom
you can just bring them home and
like say
if you're going to do the whole multiple
wives thing you gotta you gotta do it
ethically you know what i'm saying you
gotta do it the right way
let them all know yeah yeah no no i i i
agree without you on that point
you can't be out there just do what you
want um
no no no you can but you have to
disclose that
right but but then again there's there's
a way to do it
where everyone's good with it
yo you didn't come home last night what
happened babe your job is to be like
they said your mom [ __ ] up
i saw this [ __ ] she was brazilian
hawaiian her ass was ridiculous
activity's on point then she looked at
me funny
and my dick got hard so i [ __ ] up my
bad you supposed to be able to do that
hey listen i agree i i agree
yeah i agree with you i agree with you
110 on that you should be able to do
that
thing is most women are not you for one
and two
even though you say a lot of them would
be accepting of that i can guarantee you
vast majority because you want to know
why we're raising a society where we
tell men
you got to be the loyal one you got to
be monogamous you got to make it work
you got to marry her take care of the
family that's how we raise people
and then we teach girls better get your
wedding day get your wedding dress he
can only be faithful to you if the man's
gonna cherish you blah blah blah
so when you're indoctrinating that even
though you're talking like this and i
can
feel you on that most people are not
gonna they're not gonna rock with that
they're not gonna rock with that people
don't live in the real
world i agree in a nine to five
hamster wheel that they run the same
race every day in a box you ever seen a
hamster
yeah it's a glass cage giving you the
illusion that you're living your life
but you live in a [ __ ] hamster wheel
you haven't experienced [ __ ]
i'm gonna say that i i get what you're
saying about the hamster wheel you know
even the 95 the nine to five thing is
not the issue for me for me it's like
people are disillusioned in regards to
how
a lot of marriages and a lot of
relationships work people talk about
like oh my god people cheat so much
state [ __ ]
your grandfather had a second family
yeah yeah they don't they
like a lot of infidelity's been
happening for a long time that we just
never talked about we romanticized the
past as if there was a time where
cheating wasn't rampant or or
or infidelity wasn't common so i think i
have an issue with and this is not even
like just a
nine to five hamster but i know artists
who are disillusioned about this
i know people uh from the streets who
are disillusioned about this like
it really comes down to whether or not
you're actually knowledgeable and you've
done a bit of research or
you've experienced things that's been my
experience generally so i think from
experience
experience will definitely be one of the
teachers yeah
yeah yeah also education
yeah like a lot of people want to
understand what you're saying but they
can't understand it because
they've never experienced it yeah yeah
it's
but you talk like this right and they'll
listen to you and they'll be like oh my
god what she's saying is so gross
what's she saying is the truth of the
world so i don't want to say
right but that's what i mean i live i'm
like
i'm like that that that sin that it's
coming out and be like hey yo listen
this is what's really going on with you
with your with this with this side of
the world that we live on
taboo and that's how we capitalize
is on the tabooness of it so when i do
speak out in the open it's kind of like
don't tell me the truth because i like
living in my life you're [ __ ] up my
fantasy
yeah yeah you know everybody wants that
they want the man that's just gonna
i'm gonna tell you what what a woman
wants right the one man is gonna come
home
and say hi honey how was your day
shower them with anything they want they
don't want to feel like that i'm not
talking about buying them gifts and [ __ ]
that's just so petty i'm talking about
being able to provide for her
without her ever feeling the need like
we can't attain the foods that we want
or the experiences that we want a woman
wants to feel like she's
like you're grateful to have her because
a woman would commit to you
without a fault and give you her 100
everything she will empty her soul into
a man
and a man just doesn't know how to
say please don't empty yourself into me
because
i have about five other [ __ ] that are
empty that i'm emptying myself into
[Laughter]
that's a crazy point but yo listen
actually we could have kept going for
another hour and a half but i gotta go
because
this has been fire honestly we'll
definitely have to do a second one like
this because this is good to chop it up
with you
uh but real quick where can people find
you just before i like kind of wrap up
this
need already main channel nina raider
vlogs is a stripper channel nina already
eats is the eating show channel and
honestly i want to say thank you
honestly thank you so much for this
opportunity because
believe it or not um just to get serious
on a real note um
believe it or not i don't know if my
son's watching so i appreciate you
giving me this platform
out to my son maximus greenwood i have
to take advantage of it and say that i
love you so much
and i'm working hard puppy yeah yeah
thank you
do you no for real yeah no worries noise
uh all right listen i'm gonna i'm gonna
end on
those beautiful talking thank you peace
uh let me just switch over here oh yeah
so for a lot of you are watching who may
not know what that last portion was
about
um apparently as i understand it is that
she
is not allowed to see her son when some
of you be like oh whatever this and that
you might have your opinions but at the
end of the day
um you know apparently the circumstance
outside of her control
doesn't have that opportunity so um
yeah she communicates with him how she
can and uh
that was that portion that was crazy man
she's awesome
i like talking to her she's she's real
people and maybe it's because the way i
was raised in the environments i was at
um but i like talking to people that are
real
that's just me personally i could i
could i could chop it up with her
for hours and i would enjoy it because i
know
that she'd been through things so for me
to listen to her is enjoyable
now some of you may not approve the
lifestyle whatever it is she got a
non-lodge and a lot of
information that i think is impertinent
and i like her perspective so
that was fun man i enjoyed that i really
enjoyed that
and um yeah
yeah i wish i could have unpacked the
sun stuff with her because i felt like
she dropped a bomb on y'all y'all didn't
get a chance to get it
but uh she got a video about it i'll
probably link it i haven't watched it in
full
uh but she talks about you know
her son and all that stuff so maybe you
all want to do a bit of research but uh
yeah we're gonna bring on the second
person for the second date
uh so let me just go through that
process and while i'm doing that you
know what i'm saying let me just uh
let me just play a little bit of music
for y'all
oh
foreign
all right all right uh that was so much
fun man i really enjoyed that that was
that was a lot of fun she was really
cool
all right let me just hit up homegirl
for the second one
and then we'll get this popping
hopefully you guys are enjoying guys if
you're in the chat and you guys have had
a good time or you've been enjoying this
leave a one in the chat
okay uh hey
join us
let me just keep playing a bit of music
while we uh
so yeah we're going to date number two
uh
in the criminal justice system sexually
based offenses are considered especially
heinous
in new york city the dedicated
detectives who investigate these vicious
felonies are members of an elite squad
known as the special victims unit
these are their stories damn this [ __ ]
goes hard bro
this [ __ ] goes hard all right here we go
hey kathy how you doing
all right folks we got our yes yes i can
hear you you want to try turning on the
camera
yeah uh let me know when you're good
you got this i believe in you uh where
is it oh
yeah there's a little button you got to
press the camera button
all the way from france oh okay seems
like she left
uh you want to try that again there
should be a button that says turn on
camera
it says no video permission oh wait well
let me just check here
you should try uh hold up
here you should have video permission
now just click on it now
so it's it's waiting queue right no no
no you're already in the spot so don't
move anymore just click on
turn on video oh my gosh am i that bad
it's okay not everyone's good at discord
so i believe in you you got this
all right okay we are we are are we in
okay hold up let me let me just move
this around over here
okay hold up let me do this okay we're
here
all right kathy is your name actually
kathy
uh yeah yeah well no actually it's not
kathy's just
uh what people usually call me okay is
there a name you prefer i use is there
like a nickname or anything like that
great
kathy's great okay cool catherine
catherine
catherine sounds too official like you
should be royalty from the buckingham
palace i know yeah it sounds too
official
it sounds too formal so i tend to use
kathy you have a very like english
england accent
was that is that my favorite yeah
unfortunately
yeah unfortunately is that where you're
from
uh no i'm from france you're from france
okay you speak with such a
english english because i lived in
the uk for a little bit so i did there
and um i lived there for two years when
i was a bit younger as well
okay you know what's crazy right now is
i hear both accents so it's like
throwing me the [ __ ] off because i'm
like
and then i also hear the english at the
same time so i'm like bugging right now
yeah yeah yeah certain words that you
say like the way that you say it i can
hear the french intonation
so it's kind of interesting because i
was in the south when i was like really
young
and i was in the north when i was at
university so i kind of picked up
a little bit of the northern accent and
then a little bit of the southern accent
so it's it's
yeah it's a weird accent in the end
really young
there's a way to speak english like this
oh i can do it i can still do it yeah we
got a lot of french people here i'd be
hating
on them all the time so one so when i
hate
you thought i was english from where
actually you heard english
because every time i heard the video it
was always um preach that was speaking
in french
yeah yeah yeah preach speaks french i
also speak french my first language is
french
but i i don't speak it too often anymore
but i'm still very comfortable i can
have a full-on conversation
okay yeah yeah yeah but yeah i i'd be
hating on french people
yeah we could i think most of the
audience is english so we're not gonna
be doing that but it's crazy because um
uh yeah i used to i'm so used to hating
on french people all the time
that i've like i've learned oh yeah but
it's fine because
everybody hates on french people so it's
perfectly fine not as much as canadian
you guys
access no there's no way i can i can
honestly tell you
if you travel like most of europe like
french people are like
most people you know don't like them but
when it comes to canadians if i rock a
canadian flag and i'll go somewhere
people like i'm a young
chill
it looks nice i haven't been there yeah
yeah you're missing out you're missing
out okay
if you like if you like feel like
freedoms and stuff it's a great time
but i was going to ask why do people
hate the french
are you oh you don't know no are you
serious
yeah yeah that they're rude okay okay
i'm gonna do something real quick yo
everybody in the chat okay if you
dislike french
people okay from friends put a one if
you love french people from france put a
two okay
i just want to see and be honest don't
don't don't don't ride for me
have your own opinion okay one in the
chat if you like everybody love the
friends
i'm telling you right now i'm telling
you right now they do not okay
and especially here uh because we get so
many french immigrants who come down
here
um to live in montreal so so when they
come down
man there's always beefs there's always
problems uh because
you guys have a a bit of a you know like
um
you know like like a bit of a snobby
attitude
okay snobby yeah okay yeah i've heard
that before oh yeah okay here we go
there you go
everyone's putting a bunch of ones in
the chat everybody already knows
it's okay
if you need to see it you can see it
it's going crazy they're all putting
once
but hold up when you travel
when you travel are you speaking french
most of the time are you speaking
english
when i travel i speak english most of
the time
okay that's why people cannot speak okay
yeah
that's why people don't even know that
you're from france because they don't
even associate your accent with
um it yeah well sometimes they they say
they hear it on on some words that i say
but uh
yeah if i hear it a little bit it's not
an issue but like if i really like if
you were the picture perfect
like if you were like a french person
from france like if they saw that
there's definitely a different attitude
but i don't wanna i wouldn't say they
walk away
but there's a immediate like oh uh
because again it's one of those things
where french people have a
uh a very known attitude for okay
there's two of them okay there's two
non-stereotypes about french people okay
okay
that are bad okay the one is that you
guys are super snobby
which from my personal experience like
there's a bit of an elitist
attitude all right i went to i went to
dc i've been a lot of time around french
people i i believe
some of that to be true
no not in france just the french people
that i constantly meet like i went to uh
uh france has a lot of nissa's all over
the world where they bring french
teachers from france to come down and
teach
in a lot of different countries so when
i lived in ethiopia i was with a french
teacher
uh and the second one is like that you
guys don't shower
that was the second there was sour yeah
you guys smell man
no no no no no no that's 100
and you know what was crazy is i i
didn't believe it but preach swears by
it he's like i worked at nightclubs the
french people a lot of them do not
do not shower really no that's that's
not true
okay i know there's one it's not the
shower thing it's the hairy thing that
people say french people are very hairy
and stuff
and they don't shave and whatnot but
i've never had another one
hold up okay you know what just so i
don't be talking [ __ ] i'm gonna just
pull up
hold up you know what just because i
don't want to be the one who says this
stuff okay
so french people don't
shower i'm gonna put this in google okay
okay
okay there's surveys okay i don't know
how accurate this is okay
but i'm gonna pull it up on the screen
okay um
here let me just let me try to do this
okay i'm gonna okay i'm gonna check some
canadian stereotypes let's see
oh you know you don't have to be petty
this is not a petty argument i just
this is again i'm just i'm just thinking
just to know you know
okay okay yeah most of them are very
positive i'm not gonna lie to you we're
very kind etc etc
okay chat so chat just so you guys know
i'm not just making this up okay
here it is all right i just pulled it up
on chat i'm gonna read the headline they
say
most french people don't shower every
day study shows
okay here we go all right here we go
okay while there are numerous
stereotypes about the french that are
completely inaccurate it turns out that
the whole french people don't shower
thing may indeed be true
hold up a new poll conducted by bva and
published in a french newspaper
okay reveals that only 50
57 of the french people
that's not a lot that's fit that's
almost half people
50 percent of french people shower daily
24 okay i'm gonna keep reading this it
gets better okay
24 said they shower once every other day
and eleven percent said they shower once
every three days
the remaining eight percent the
remaining eight percent
shower once every four days or less
and when the french are in the shower
it's not for very long either the study
found that french person spends on
average
nine minutes a day in the shower that's
like the amount of time it takes to i
don't know
they included some jokes but anyways i
don't know how accurate this is this is
a stereotype i've heard a lot and um
i've never heard of this one but okay
but you know it's it's the natural smell
maybe i don't know
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah natural smell
they like maybe
yeah yeah yeah yeah so that was it but
i'm sure you shower every day so you're
good you're good
yeah this is the perfect way to start a
date you know
hey man i heard your people just
straight up with prejudice i heard your
people don't shower
i still haven't found any canadian
stereotypes but um oh
they're all positive oh canadian people
are very welcoming they're very kind
they have a huge country they like
beavers they live in igloos
stuff like that really okay actually
much uh canadian people so like
you're the one who's going to give me
the whole view of canadian people oh
yeah i'm the perfect representation of
canadians
just look at me don't i don't i look
like a poster child for canada
yes you do you really do okay yeah so um
i actually want to ask you i don't even
know but what is it that you you do for
your day to day um i'm a teacher i'm an
english teacher
oh okay all right i have a thing for
teachers let's go let's go teachers
yeah i love it you know just the people
who spend all day you know
working with kids and then they also
have summers off it's like
it's fantastic and then you guys it's so
good yeah and when the last place i was
working at we had
um a nap in between so i was teaching
really small children
and every time the children would go to
sleep then we'd have a nap as well at
the same time
oh wait what what grade what grade
um there were zero from no not zero
obviously but from zero to six years old
okay okay all right so we're like you
like teaching like
little tiny children um i prefer it but
right now i'm teaching
all ages all different ages it's a
different thing like with children it's
a bit um
more repetitive and it's a bit more
games and stuff like that and with
adults it's uh
it's okay so interesting so so what's
the oldest that you teach
uh the oldest person i had was my last
student he was i think
45 45.
okay so so okay all right hold up what's
going on right here so
how are you teaching 45 year olds i'm
confused are you are you tutoring like
how's that working
can i ask um no so i'm teaching them so
they come to
the center that i'm working for at the
moment
and um they are preparing for exams
so they've got the lingua skill exams or
the cambridge test
that they're trying to pass and so they
um
book sessions for like for example 30
hours and they do intensive english
teaching okay and you're the one
basically who tutors them right
uh yeah okay just want to make sure i
understand i was like oh [ __ ] this
sounds complicated as hell
okay that's interesting so you tutor
people
and then you also teach young classes
well i used to do that more before
i do it once in a while but
okay cool i um i actually
if i it's funny i said this to myself if
if this whole comedy thing didn't work
out when i started like six years ago i
actually wanted to be a teacher i wanted
to teach history
but i only wanted to teach to adults i
always liked and i said adults what did
you want to teach
seventeen to like eighteen history
history
okay so you're interested in history
yeah yeah that was like the only class
uh that and like creative writing those
were the only two classes in high school
that i uh paid attention and so uh those
were all the subjects that i interested
that i thought were interesting so so
yeah so when you said you were a teacher
i was like damn she's doing what i
wanted to
before i was doing youtube i was dancing
professionally you were what sorry
dancing oh okay what kind of dogs
oh man you already know i mean we out
here in the club no ah
the youtube video is out or you're
dancing no no
no no no no no i don't i don't need that
kind of attention but
i used to teach salsa and uh hip-hop so
those were the two things
and i used to dance professionally so i
did a couple of projects here and there
you know what i'm saying um yeah that's
what i need to do
uh youtube is something i started so
this is
people don't know this but before i did
the whole app and preach stuff i um i
did youtube
back in 2013. my first video ironically
enough went
viral and so i was like man i'm good at
this then i didn't make another video
for like two years and
um i was just i liked making video
projects i like putting
thoughts together and like piecing it
and then like telling a story
um so that's what i used to do okay
interesting
yeah for how long
so if we go based off when i really
start uh
when i first put out a video it would be
since 2013 but the truth is
probably i started about five years ago
for real frill okay yeah yeah so that's
how long i've been at it but you know
yeah
i mean youtube's got it's ups and downs
it's perks it's downsides
uh but yeah there's oh man privacy
you know it's like um
people watch you and they feel like they
know you and they feel like you're
friends and so sometimes in person
they're really weird
and i'm i'm a chill person i'm super
proud like you know if i'm in the subway
you know i mean i got my hoodie on don't
bother me
you know i'm just moving point a to
point b don't want to
bother anyone but uh sometimes people
people are really weird like people just
follow you
yeah they follow okay this is what i
expect
i feel like and this is going to sound
arrogant but i feel like being
like known or being recognized is like
it's like being a hot girl you you deal
with um a lot of the weird stuff like
people following you you know people
just getting in your bubble for no
reason
people just saying weird stuff to you so
um that's like the best
parallel i could draw okay so how how's
everything like um what about with girls
like how's it how is it since
um from before you were doing youtube to
right now like how did it turn with
dating yeah yeah yeah i mean for for
dating and stuff like that it's it's
definitely different i i don't date
nearly as much now that i did before
because i just don't have the time like
i could i couldn't you know before i was
i was out in the streets i was for the
streets i was living on the streets it
was a great time
uh but then now that i'm you know what
that means right
uh kind of i think so without you okay
so okay
huh look at what like tug life like
like yeah
is that what you mean uh she said like
thug life
um so basically when you when someone
says he's for the streets it just means
uh basically that they're out there
being a [ __ ] you know
uh all right okay okay okay yeah okay
you were from the streets okay
yeah exactly exactly that means you know
you know how the street is like a public
space
was that so you were more of a [ __ ]
when you
before you started youtube then now oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah i was just
supposed to feel different because now
that you're doing youtube and you're a
bit um you're you're like
successful on youtube you should get
more look at look at my saturday look at
my look
look at my saturday i gotta stream all
day i gotta prep for these things i
gotta constantly create the appointments
i have to edit other videos
i have to do another live stream later
on today and then tomorrow's more live
streams more setting up of interviews
and then i gotta put out videos like six
seven times like
where am i gonna find the time to woo a
woman um
okay you feel what i'm saying how can i
be in these streets if i'm on front of
my computer all day long
i'm on camera there's no time for me to
be on the street
okay okay so that that's like the
difficulty of it i i do all the editing
and [ __ ] like that so
you know i mean i can't uh i can't be
out here can't be out here
but you know it's cool i like it i'm
chilling i'm just focused on the work
right now so that's a good
change of pace this is like this is the
these dates are the only times
that i've been on dates in probably like
the last six seven months so yeah okay
yeah yeah so wait so wait you just
thought i was out here just being like
you know i'm a youtuber hey girl what
what's your number what's your name
yeah yeah that's what you thought
no i actually i prefer it you don't need
to
because obviously like if you're a
youtuber and you're successful
you probably already have like lots of
your subscribers like girls and stuff
yeah you don't need to i generally i
generally i generally prefer it if
people don't follow what i do
okay yeah yeah yeah that's the one thing
i loved about dating apps for a while is
like i could still be on dating apps and
meet people
who didn't know what i did and just have
like a regular ass conversation you know
what i'm saying
whereas now if i go on a date it's
people like
they've watched so much of the content
they're like man yeah you remember what
you said about this about your mom and i
was like
when did i tell you this but they've
watched videos so like
they have a proximity to me that i don't
have to them
you understand it's like if you know if
everything that you ever did was online
and
out there will you never get a clean
slate you never get to
really show who you are the person
because they're already coming in with a
huge idea of who you are
okay yeah yeah you know so so that's
some of the downsides and so
it can be tough to to feel comfortable
with that so generally
i prefer people who are not involved so
you actually need to
when you meet someone who has never
heard of you
yeah it's refreshing because you know i
just like talking to people
and and it's i'm getting to know you
you're getting to know me but i don't
have that experience i don't get that
privilege
when you already know all this stuff
about me or you've heard these things or
you have these ideas you know
people talk people have an idea of me
and then they meet me in person like oh
you're way more chill and i'm like
okay yeah i guess they make their own
idea based on what they see on
videos exactly exactly because you know
sometimes a video i'm yelling or i'm
cracking jokes but like
who i am on stage is just like a portion
of me it's not necessarily a real
reflection of me as an entire person
but you only see me in that format you
know it's like people who come to comedy
shows and they see me cracking jokes and
they're laughing the whole time
they come talk to me off stage like oh
man i thought you were like always funny
and i'm like no i'm not always telling
jokes you know like
when i'm off stage i'm just a regular
ass person you know so
um so i think that's like some of the um
the weirdness what about you how many of
your students have you dated
of my students hey yay let's
okay so you just started dating the
adult students
[Music]
we've got nothing to do with each other
anymore but okay that student's coming
back apparently he was happy with me
sir maybe i was on a date next okay the
one the 45 year old
yeah the 45 year old hey look at you you
know i mean for you
age is just a number you're out here
i'm looking at you i'm guessing you're
like 27
i'm 27. yeah
oh chad don't check i said 27. i dead
ass
play the tape back stop playing with me
i dead ass just said 27
yo chat i'm expecting some donations
stop playing with me
i don't know what it is about me i look
at somebody i'm like
i know what age you are that's why like
if an underage girl try to talk to me
like it's not gonna happen i'd be like
you know exactly smells like jail and i
just said what
gave it away what gave it away
you know what though it's hard for me to
tell you all the mental calculations
like i factored in the butt stuff
your sense of style your facial features
you know i mean all this stuff like
you clearly weren't in your 30s i mean
yeah yeah quick maths
quick math so you know i think i noticed
is like uh when it comes to french
people the
one of the noises that they have a hard
time with is th
like like the that's the sound yeah yeah
because you didn't you didn't say you
didn't say thug life you went tug life
i love it let's go yeah
there's little things like that that i
find so peculiar but that they're so
indicative of so much
or in the french language people just in
general like
how people say certain words um you can
often times tell like where they're from
where they were raised what's their
first language like people struggling
with certain words like
if i hear junior go say good day
victoria
uh if you can't say his uh v's he's
probably from a spanish or latin country
and you know depending yeah yeah yeah so
you can you can peep a lot of stuff so
my mind accent what's your favorite
accent
brazilian the brazilian accent is the
most unsexy
but hilarious act do you have to make
sure that you're going to make love to
her
oh it's way better because you know the
indian accent's funny don't get me wrong
i enjoy it you know like
a good day but um the brazilian accent
for me is like it's like it's like this
a single song that you have too
it's um it's constantly waved so i enjoy
that accent the most that's my favorite
what about you what's your favorite
indian for sure really i love the indian
accent yeah it's funny
it's good and i love the indian music
and stuff so
i quite like it well you [ __ ] with
bollywood
uh uh no i don't really watch the movies
i listen to the music of it
the movie are a bit i used to watch the
old ones
i'm just gonna say i was kind of
prejudiced the way you moved your head
um do you go to
do you go to do you go to indian
restaurants do you ever tip more if they
got a thick accent
oh i used to i used to work in an indian
restaurant actually you know pakistani
same thing oh sorry if someone's from
india pakistan but yeah i used to work
in a pakistani restaurant um
the food is amazing i love it yeah but
um
no they don't they don't really tape now
no but do you tip
do you tip when you hear next yeah like
when you
yeah like if you go to that restaurant
and they got a thick ass accent they're
like hey good day
whatever you know like do you tip more
money i not because of the accent maybe
because if the star is good i will maybe
i'm gonna be honest with you me
personally if i hear a thick ass
brazilian accent you get an extra twenty
dollars like i'm just
i'm so happy i get to hear it and see
that people are gonna
fake it oh they could try i can smell it
boy so i'll just start talking to
portuguese make sure they actually speak
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah so what were
some of the things that you may have
been worried about or like nervous about
coming on this date
um saying stupid things i hope i don't
like i don't uh that's that's all why
would you think you're gonna say stupid
things people in the chat are loving you
they're like yo who is this girl she's
awesome people i think
i think if you don't date students
before that you're definitely going to
date them now there's a bunch of
students right now who are looking at
you like
i want you to be my teacher you know so
just letting you know
are french people looking at this yes
so we have a lot of people who speak
french for sure okay yeah yeah i get i
get french dms all the time about people
like
oh and people are sending me stuff so
yeah oh nice okay yeah but i want to ask
you what you should do
videos in french no no no no no no
never never never know because right now
our market's mostly english so there's
no reason to
but i wanted to ask you what's uh what's
what's the dating life like in in france
versus like
maybe the uk or whatever like i don't
know because i haven't been in france
that long so i came back i came back um
right when corona virus started
i wasn't in france until now so i can't
tell you to be
honest so you you were in the uk before
this
uh no before this i was in china so i
was teaching in china
okay and then um and i
came back so it was doing when the whole
curvy thing started was during the
chinese new years so the chinese
holidays and i
left i went to the philippines at that
time hold up
which month did you leave china i left
in
february in january
january 2020 yes oh so you were bringing
the the virus with you everyone you
you left china you're like hey welcome
to the philippines i was just in wuhan
yeah yeah yeah okay okay yeah all this
time we were blaming chinese people
turns out
it was girls with cute english accents
who are out here spreading it
stop playing with me okay so so you went
to the philippines and then after that
and then i decided because it was kind
of getting crazy and it was still a
holiday
so we didn't have any classes at school
so i decided to come back to france for
a month and i think
six days or five days before my flight
all the
all the time all the things what about
before china where were you before china
uh before china i was um for
four years well a few years in
england okay okay all right all right
all right we got it we got it okay so
tell me about like the dating life
differences between england china japan
like yo
hit me like when you were out there in
these streets what was going on sure are
you sure you want to hear
oh hell yeah everybody wants to hear
let's go stop playing with me
um which one should i start with china
okay china is very interesting
um well asian it's
it's i don't really date much in asia
because
um actually asian people have asian men
have got like
a lot of a very different style of women
that they
are attracted to what do you mean they
don't they're not in love with black
women
not really not really so like a lot of
people you know in the west were like oh
yeah
you can't say this you can't say that
about in china they don't care like
they love fair skin like they really
like really white skin
have to be very very slim and um
feminine women they're attracted to and
you're yeah
and you're a little and you're a little
too thick for their their their tastes
ah well i was a little bit bigger before
so yeah i was definitely
hey i put a one in the chat for thick
girls you know what i'm saying t-h-i-c-c
okay cool so you were too thick for them
back then
they're dating what they do the thing
that i didn't like
much was um a lot of them
instead of like going and having a
conversation with a girl
they would just be like oh i'm buying
you this so if you go to a bar
and you're a bunch of foreign girls so i
had a russian girl that's like
that's got a lot of success there
instead of like going up and talk
talking to her they'll just buy her a
drink put it on her table and think oh
because i'm buying her stuff
then she's going to like me so it's very
like transactional there so they kind of
understand like
women are more interested in like um you
know
if i buy you like bollywood albums
you're not going to just come on a date
with me
it depends which ones you buy it depends
which ones that's why yo guys you
already heard it here first
slide an album on the table be like
maybe i'll see you later
if you pick the wrong ones definitely in
no
don't worry don't we got some indian
bros in the chat they know what they're
doing
okay so so so you felt like this
transaction what about england you were
there for four years like what was
popping when you were there
because you were you know england we we
like we like we like you know i mean i
heard the english men like the black
women you know what i'm saying they like
them thick
yeah i like english men yeah englishmen
are very friendly they're very um
you can have like um good conversations
and a lot of banter it's really yeah i
like every neck english man
so you had good dating experiences there
um
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
okay and then and then you went
there's no i don't know there's no
chemistry with me and japanese men i
guess
but i've had really good friendships
instead with japanese men so i can be
like really good friends
with japanese men and um more than
i'd be dating them you you can't speak
japanese though right
i can't speak japanese yeah or you can
speak japanese
yes why because i
so i went to japan when i was in high
school
so i um i lived in a
homestay family so i lived with a family
there and i went to high school so i
i had no choice oh my god
that's crazy you speak to japanese oh
how many wait i
just added french english japanese i'm
assuming i could be wrong you speak
mandarin maybe
oh no i wouldn't say i speak it like
okay
okay okay okay what any other languages
um i did korean but i think i've
pretty much forgotten
i i i started to joke about how like i
always whenever i heard kareem speaking
i didn't understand a word but i always
thought they were complaining
because everything finishes in japanese
when you hear it
no not at all no no the the they all
that one always threw me off when they
make that noise at the end of their
words
uh but no it doesn't sound at all
similar to japanese for me why
okay have you been to japan before no
never
never uh i mean i might visit
it's not one of those i know so many
people who like really want to go to
japan in asia for me i've just never
been that curious
so maybe i'll end up there one day but
it's not on my list of places to visit
okay okay well you surprised by that
yeah cause you like you seem to like
animes love anime
i watch a lot of anime i'm i'm deep in
that enemy the people who like
anime want to go to japan and they they
want to waifu
and they want her yeah
i'm not into any of that i'm not into
any of that i like
um and i noticed that that was one thing
i had a conversation with people about
like just because i love anime doesn't
mean i'm obsessed with japanese culture
you know what i'm saying it's just
i enjoy i enjoy anime i watch a lot of
animes i read a lot of mangas et cetera
et cetera
but i've never been someone who's been
like whoa cherry blossom trees and
[ __ ] cute girls and hey cherry
blossom trees are awesome they're really
good
i mean yes they look beautiful i'm not
taking a 30 hour flight to go see them
okay okay if you could travel to one
place
where would it be brazil
no i've already been no would have been
it's a good time wonderful place
lots of lots of lots of good times
where would you go
am i still curious about any place
not really i don't think there's a i
don't think it's like a destination i
desperately want to go
to just really like canada
i might no it's not that it's not that i
just traveled a lot i've kind of seen
all the places i wanted to go to so like
i'm just i'm chilling now but if i had
to pick some place
i'll probably pick um moldova probably
moldova okay yeah have you ever dated a
moldovian is that how you say it woman
not at all it just sounds cool it
reminds me of like a lord of the rings
in mordor you know like it just sounds
like a place i want to go to
like i want to go there and like it's
got to be like a volcano in the middle
of it
and like it's just dark and gray and ash
everywhere and just like
hard [ __ ] who i've had to
endure a lot i want to just go there for
a day and then leave
okay yeah so yeah what about you what's
the place that you got to go to
um which place would i go to um
to visit i probably go back to japan i
really like japan yeah
yeah um just to visit though
okay what what is it that you like about
there
i i love that it's a different world
it's a whole different world i
i like that it's it's training it's like
you've got a lot of um
different places where they put the town
and like one's going to have this weird
atmosphere
and then you go to a different side of
town and it's got this other weird
atmosphere it's like it's
a lot of them you know you see the
tradition and the culture
and at the same time it's very modern so
it's like that mix of the two is
so so interesting to me okay good you
should
the right answer was canada by the way
but i mean if you want to [ __ ] this up
i'm just playing with you just playing
with you never been interested in going
to canada actually
i don't know why america canada's never
but i should hold up you've never been
to america i've never been to america
oh you gotta go to america and oh man
it's unbelievable
it's crazy i've been all over the world
america is special
america is like i would compare it to
like um 10 countries put into one
you know you go to new york and then you
go to
florida then you go to atlanta and then
you go to [ __ ]
new orleans and louisiana then you go to
texas then you go to
and they're different they speak
different they act different they live
different they eat different
it's uh it's very fascinating it's like
uh
it's like it's like national geographics
every day
it's a good time okay okay how do you
recommend it
yeah yeah yeah before you go back to
japan you got to go there
okay yeah you're going to be amazed and
you're going to be disgusted at the same
time it's
one of the most amazing things i've ever
experienced living in america for a
couple years yeah
are you taking notes are you writing
stuff down oh no no no i'm just playing
with my
cup of tea okay okay cool it looked like
you were taking notes i was like yo she
about to write a biography on me there's
an article coming up
yeah yeah yeah no no uh when what
have you have you been on any dates
during this pandemic you haven't uh
taken any chances
um i've been on a date
uh i've been on a date with yeah i've
seen someone like
uh going on a picnic something like that
hey guys you know what a picnic is that
means yeah we can go in public it's
something safe
but we're not going back to nobody's
place yeah
yeah yeah i went there i had that and
otherwise no
no no i haven't been dating now what
happened so
how can we how can we out and go for for
more picnic dates what happened
um
because well there's there's the whole
lockdown thing and it's like
uh-huh nah stop lying what happened what
happened what happened tell the truth
stop lying
[Music]
it was nice it was really nice i had
good conversation
and um just
that's it didn't think more yeah you
didn't see more
going yeah i don't think there's
anything wrong as long as you're not
name-dropping black
you know like another really nice person
really really nice just no there's no
chemistry beyond that yeah yeah
sometimes just
the chemistry they're not for you it's
interesting you can you can get along
with someone be cool
and just not want to see that person or
be interested in them in any other way
yeah that's actually not feel like you
want to
i don't know yeah and and then people
are like oh let's be
friends and everything but you don't
really want to be friends
no friends for what no no no i'll be
cordial always be cool i'll never have a
bad thing to say about you but i'm not
going to be friends with you that's
awkward
i don't like what you think of of men
and women being friends
i mean yeah it works for some people not
for me generally but
yeah okay yeah like i could be on really
great teams
no ma'am no ma'am but i got a lot of
these ladies i know who i'm really cool
with where i'm not
sexual within any type of boy but i
wouldn't call them my friends
we're cordial we're cool maybe we'll see
each other at events maybe we'll
organize like a party they'll show up
but i wouldn't call them my friends my
friends are people
i talk to on a regular basis who i'm
close with and uh yeah
yeah yeah that's that's it what about
you you got a lot of male friends tell
me allah
tell us um no not really not really
either
um i've got lots of like
my closest friends are female um and
the closest friend male friend that i
have yeah like i said it was it was
mostly in japan
or um the last person i was working with
when i was in china
that's about it otherwise not really no
but i'm cool like i'm friendly
i'm friendly with men but you wouldn't
say you were friends
so i think last thing i want to ask why
do you call yourself
harry kathy um
i couldn't think of another name and
like because i changed my hair
like because i do hair i was like oh
harry kathy and like people think french
people are hairy so i just
i don't know yeah i actually knew that
people were gonna like
make drinks about this yeah it's just
one of those names
if you try to google it it just shows
you porn so that's how i was like damn
she went
oh yeah you can't imagine why harry
kathy would be
a porn category oh oh
okay yeah hey it was just a funny
observation i know you just
you have like a lot of hair stuff on
your on your on your ig so i thought
that was interesting but uh
but yeah i just left at the name because
i had to actually type it out i'm like
harry kathy
[Laughter]
well listen i actually got to wrap this
up because it was a lot of fun did you
enjoy yourself
yeah it was really fun yeah yeah there's
nothing to be nervous about right you
came on here everyone thought you were
awesome
really fun well thanks for having me no
no problem and where can people find
you if you want to just say that my
instagram so it's uh
harry kathy yeah yeah it's not it's not
it's not porn no no you have some hair
stuff if you want to check it out
your hair looks fabulous by the way yeah
you look a little fantastic yeah yeah
yeah so
guys go check that out and yeah that's
pretty much it thanks
all right thanks for having me bye bye
and
that folks is it for date number two
um yeah she was mad cool she was a lot
of fun
uh i enjoyed myself
let me just make sure i didn't [ __ ]
anything up no we're good
uh let me just make sure actually change
the permissions
connect no nobody should be able to
connect cool
um yeah man we had a lot of fun this is
a great convo it's a lot of fun
i'm going to be doing a live stream for
dungeons and dragons in about 30 minutes
on my second channel which is abba zaba
atlas
if you guys enjoyed this live stream uh
be sure to show some love drop a like
whatever you want to say let me just
check out a few of these super chats
while i take some questions from the
chat real quick
and then i'll tell you guys what i
thought about everything today all right
all right would love to take
kathy to toyama bay just a few hours
from tokyo was the only thing i really
wanted to do last time i was in japan
that i didn't
hey man well yeah i'm saying maybe maybe
you'll get that chance
for what it's worth guys we don't
actually believe in the ludicrous stuff
you see on the social media
about us we're just really political
always have been
okay i don't know who that was directed
to or what he was talking about
yo why is it that i can't see [ __ ]
super chats what's that about why isn't
i can't see the people
who donated earlier that's trash bro
y'all y'all ran me some cash and i can't
scroll up to say nothing
um that's unfortunate sorry guys if you
donated earlier and i miss your super
chats i really apologize
i'll be on the second channel okay okay
so yes
uh abba are you asking her out or nah uh
hey man i guess you're just gonna have
to stay tuned and find out you know what
i'm saying
uh but she was really cool i enjoyed
both my dates
you know i enjoyed both my dates they
were both great
uh the first one was fantastic she was
high energy it was a different vibe
second girl
much different feel uh and i enjoyed
both them so
you know hopefully you guys enjoyed the
conversation you guys took away some
notes
and yeah i'll be on the second channel
so if you want to chat more about this
we can be there so go to abba zaba atlas
on youtube and uh you guys can talk to
me there about all the stuff you saw
here
deuces